we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here is yet again troy York
calling in he has problems with Bernie
Sanders this time he is not presenting
with a different name but he's using
what appears to be a fake accent or sort
of voice yet another one of the multiple
personalities of Troy York take a listen
Rahman uh I want to say that Bernie
Sanders and the birdie grows the biggest
most dangerous threat to democracy this
world in this country our faces and
Keith Urban on GQ calm is a paid anti
Trump pack and I hope you are not one
too
thank you I hope not to also thank you
what are we up to like four or five
there's Cecil Brewster is one of Troy
York's personalities he has a Latino
name that sometimes he calls in with I
forget what that is so I think we're up
to at least four personalities for Troy
or I think Troy York does it all in good
fun though I mean he's definitely
trolling here but he may actually be a
legitimate fan of the show and agreed
agree with 90% of what we said he does
seem to listen to every single episode
so we've got that going for us on the
bonus show today we will talk to you
about the latest in Filipino president
rodrigo duterte s brutal drug war which
now has seen the third filipino mayor
killed in this bizarre vigilante justice
that is going on we have reviews in for
Tesla's Model 3 which now has started to
be delivered to Tesla owners and I will
tell you about the latest with the Ohio
State Fair reopening we will learn did
pat grow up going to various state fairs
did I grow up going to state fairs you
could probably know the answer at least
to that second part of the question
david pakman.com slash membership is how
you get access to the bonus show
remember that on august 12th we have a
big membership promo going on if you
want to be notified about it just get on
our mailing list at david pakman.com
sign up for our newsletter and you will
be notified and that's going to be a
huge thing folks people are telling me
it is going to be absolutely and utterly
major and if you don't want to wait and
you just want to get access to the bonus
show today you go to david pakman.com
slash membership and sign up you want to
disk
out you can use the coupon code I voted
seventeen and if you're thinking David I
just want to give you money I just want
to send you a dollar or two per month
it's as simple as going to patreon.com
slash david pakman show PA Treo ENCOM
slash david pakman show you can make a
pledge of as little as one or two
dollars per month and over 1800 of you
have already done that let's make it
happen and I will speak to you on the
bonus show in mere minutes